meet joe lowe at just 28 years old he
managed to steal over 4.4 billion
dollars in straight cash from the
malaysian governments making him have
more spending power than anyone else on
earth this is a story of how an average
teenager from an average town became an
international playboy financed the wolf
of wall street movie but his very own
private jets stole billions from a
sovereign wealth fund becoming a global
fugitive in the process that's still on
the run all before his 35th birthday and
now jolo is on the lamp low is wanted to
face criminal charges over the 1mdb
scandal
the huge mega yacht that part of our
money should be returned to malaysia let
me explain
joe lowe was born into a well-off family
definitely not billionaire kind of rich
but the i sent my kiss to international
boarding school kind of rich his family
put a lot of importance on education and
sent him to some of the best schools in
england and the us which meant joe lowe
rubs shoulders with actual wealthy
families middle eastern royalty old
money trust fund babies and the kind of
kids that would expect a supercar and a
performance by britney spears for their
birthday but despite going to the same
school joe never really felt like he
belonged when his friends came to visit
him in malaysia he used his dad's
friend's houses and luxury yachts to
pretend they were his own he made
friends with other malaysian rich kids
and even called himself the malaysian
prince at school all jo lo ever wanted
was to be accepted into high society he
would spend hours researching cool music
and hairstyles blew off school and did
anything he could to make his rich
friends respect him more but it was
never enough he was still an outsider so
when he graduated he decided to change
that
he uses years of lying faking being rich
and doing anything to fit in with the
elites to set up his very own business
that would one day make him a
billionaire
you see his life among the wealthy elite
had taught him one thing wealth and
influence or even just the appearance of
it opens doors and this lesson will make
jo lo one of the greatest con men the
world has ever seen
[Music]
[Music]
joe lowe was born on a small malaysian
island called penang his family came
from china and his dad had made millions
investing in a clothing manufacturing
business so joe and his siblings were
sent off to hero school in london one of
the most prestigious schools in the
world it all the way back in 1572 here
joe got his first taste of real riches
his family's villa and millions seemed
like a lot in malaysia but next to the
kids of middle eastern oil tycoons and
european royalty the small welfare
family had started to look like chump
change he knew that if he could just
make the right friends in the right
places he would be one step closer to
joining the wealthy elite himself so he
lied about almost everything about how
much money his family had who he was
where he lived anything to get in with
the rich kids and it worked one of his
best friends at hero was riza aziz the
stepson of a malaysian government
official who would become essential to a
scheme for university he chose the
wharton business school in pennsylvania
not because of the world class
curriculum or teachers but because
that's where donald trump and warren
buffett had attended for his 21st
birthday he spent 40 thousand dollars of
his dad's money to bug out a nightclub
in an open bar he made everyone that was
invited feel like vips because his
school years had taught him another
lesson everyone craves to feel important
make people feel important and they'll
become addicted to the drug that is you
so he played on that and when he wasn't
busy wooing the rich kids he was
plagiarizing reports from the wall
street journal for his school's
newspaper for some reason no one noticed
and joe got the reputation of being a
genius stock picker all the while
copying word for word what other people
wrote his plan was working he was making
all the right friends and building up
his social life persona far away from
home so when he graduated instead of
looking for work at an investment firm
or bank he decided to start a company of
his own little did he know the
opportunities that were about to come
his way
[Music]
joe's very first company was the winton
group he was planning to win tons of
money winton so the name stuck
he used his new middle eastern friends
to get a meeting with the guys who ran
abu dhabi's sovereign wealth fund you
can think of a sovereign wealth fund as
basically a government's hedge fund they
try to grow that money through
investments to in theory reinvest back
into the country and jolo getting his
foot into the door of abu dhabi's
sovereign wealth fund was a really big
deal because it's one of the biggest
sovereign wealth funds in the world
today it has nearly 700 billion dollars
which is as big as warren buffett's
berkshire hathaway at his initial
meeting with the fun joe realized
something crazy one of the biggest
sovereign wealth funds in the world was
run by just two young guys both in their
late 20s at the time this got him
thinking malaysia had a sovereign wealth
fund but nothing like abu dhabi's abu
dhabi's could also borrow money to
invest you could invest with leverage if
these two 20-something euros could run
abu dhabi's why couldn't he run
malaysia's but to do that he would need
someone with a lot of influence to back
him up but luckily his years of
networking had given him the perfect
person his best friend from school's
step-father the malaysian government
official najib razak at the time najib
was malaysia's deputy prime minister
just one step away from the top position
even if he didn't have the power to hand
over malaysia's money to joe he was in a
high enough position to give him all the
support he needed joe lo just needed to
get his attention by luck around the
same time jolo was seriously looking for
a way to get into najib's good graces
malaysia's sovereign wealth fund called
kazana was looking for investors for a
construction project joe immediately
called his friends in abu dhabi and got
them to agree to a meeting cleverly he
offered the jeep all the credit if the
deal went through and when it eventually
did go through he became the deputy
prime minister's favorite money man
najib's newfound popularity for making
deals happen helped him become the prime
minister in 2009 joe lowe had bided his
time and paid his dues now it was time
to cash in
[Music]
after najib became prime minister joe
lowe found himself in a position of
unlimited influence and he wasted no
time using it as soon as prime minister
najib was sworn in he approached him
with the idea of creating a new
sovereign wealth fund that would work
just like the ones in the middle east
najib had complete trust in joe's
abilities so he agreed they called it
the one malaysia development berhad or
the 1mdb fund it was supposed to invest
in green energy and tourism jobs najib
was the fund's chairman and jo lo an
unofficial advisor joe had the prime
minister in the palm of his hand joe had
helped them reach the highest point in
the malaysian governments so whatever
joe requested was as good as done just
imagine the kind of power you could have
if you had the prime minister of any
country in the palm of your hands just
two months after one mdb was created it
closed its first deal joe lowe had
convinced najib and his wife that he had
the key to middle eastern investments
and introduced them to a saudi arabian
prince the only problem was this prince
was no real prince and had no access to
the oil money when mdb were chasing
after the prince and joe discussed 1mdb
investing in the national oil company
petro saudi but here's the thing the
money they made wouldn't just go towards
developing malaysia but it would also go
towards the prime minister the prime
minister would be able to use the money
for whatever political purpose he wanted
the idea of so much money at the prime
minister's disposal must have been
tempting because it didn't take that
much time from the jeep to agree and the
deal of a lifetime was on one mdb would
invest a billion dollars into petrol
saudi just one month after meeting for
the first time the joint venture between
one mdb and petrol saudi was signed joe
lo had just successfully gotten
permission to transfer a whopping 1
billion dollars in cash from malaysia's
bank account to another bank account
but here's the thing since joe was the
one in charge of transferring that cash
he could obfuscate the transaction in a
way where it looked like the saudis got
their 1 billion dollars but in reality
it went into his own pockets
see joe was smart he had filled one mdb
staff with people loyal to him so when
the time came they arranged for just 300
mil of that 1 billion dollars to be
transferred into the actual joint
venture account with petro saudi while
the rest of the 700 million dollars
flowed not to the petrol saudi joint
venture but to good start limited a
shell company with a bank account in
switzerland the shell company was based
in the seychelles a tiny yet infamous
secrecy haven good start limited was
what's called a bearish shared company
meaning that whoever held the physical
stock certificate whoever held that
literal piece of paper in their hands
own the company and who do you think
held on to the single stock certificate
of goods star limited joe lowe and this
show company that is very hard to
connect to joe lowe just got 700 million
dollars richer in exchange from the
magic trick joe low paid over a hundred
million dollars to his two friends in
abu dhabi and after it was all said and
done joe low has successfully pulled off
one of the greatest financial frauds in
history and was now halfway there to
becoming a billionaire how did he get
away with this he explained that
malaysia had to repay a debt before the
joint venture could continue and good
start limited was actually a company
owned by the saudis i mean i don't
understand how all this high finance
works i guess i'll just believe what our
sovereign wealth manager says but jolo
was far from done
with one successful con under his belt
joe started looking for more 600 million
was great and all but there was still
opportunity to make even more so low
focused on his next targets tim lesnar
head of goldman sachs asia division he
had given him the special treatment he
learned in school he flew him out to abu
dhabi got him meetings with one of the
richest chiefs in the world and made
sure he had the complete luxury
experience why was tim lesnar a target
because he was about to get 1mdb 3.5
billion dollars from bond sales to buy
coal power plants they were going to
package these power plants into one
company and go public on the malaysia
stock exchange joe hoped this money
would help cover 1mdb's losses the only
problem was 1mdb had no credit rating so
bond sales were almost impossible which
is where tim lesnar came in he knew the
right people to brave to get the company
listed and that's exactly what he did
over the next few years goldman sachs
gave 1mdb over 5 billion from bond sales
every time they sent the money a lot of
it would be siphoned off into offshore
accounts owned by joe lowe he paid the
prime minister and tim lesnar's their
cuts and kept the rest for himself joe
lowe was still in his 20s at the time
and he had played his scheme so well
that he had governments and massive
corporations eating out the palm of his
hand and his offshore bank accounts
ballooned to billions now it was time to
enjoy the fruits of his labor
for most of the billionaires you see on
the forbes list most of their net worth
is tied up in company stock like elon
with tesla or bezos with amazon stock
but joe lowe was different his 4.4
billion dollars was in straight hard
liquid cash he had more spending power
than anyone on earth
joe lowe had finally made it he was rich
and not just comfortable kind of rich oh
no jolo was obscenely rich and now it
was time to party he would buy out clubs
throw secret parties with people like
leonardo dicaprio and paris hilton and
even gave kim kardashian a ferrari as a
wedding gift he bought a private jet
luxury yachts and multi-million dollar
mansions all over the u.s but not even
that was enough
in an incredibly ironic move jolo pretty
much financed the entire wolf of wall
street movie with money he stole from
the malaysian governments seriously not
making this up he was such great friends
with leo that he gifted him millions of
dollars of rare arts back in malaysia
people were asking questions about the
1mdb fund and how the money was being
used but with the prime minister on his
side he didn't really have much to worry
about he bought the prime minister's
wife millions in jewelry financed the
prime minister's political campaigns and
was always around when najib needed
advice in exchange the prime minister
didn't care how much joe took out of the
fund for joe there was nowhere to go but
up all he had to do was keep najib in
power and he could keep spending so he
let the prime minister hand out millions
of charities and throw massive campaign
events on an almost limitless budgets
all coming out of 1mdb joe lowe was
untouchable or so he thought
[Music]
by 2014 1mdb was hemorrhaging money it
was losing more than it could explain by
this point one mdb went from apparently
having billions to having 10 billion in
debts and only 20 million dollars in
cash
joe lope pulled a desperate move he
tried to make 1mdb shares public hoping
that the public would come flocking to
buy shares and give him some cash to
work with but that didn't work he and
goldman sachs tim lesnar had become so
caught up in the money and success that
they were blind to the trouble they were
about to face
and trouble came quicker than expected
by 2015 a swiss banker named javier
husto leads over 230 000 confidential
emails to the press in this massive data
dump was the information that would
bring joe lowe's scheme to lights a
journalist for the sarah walk reports
published an expose leaking jo lo and
prime minister najim to the disappearing
money of 1mdb this news caused a civil
war in the malaysian governments najib
and joe denied doing anything wrong but
that didn't help hundreds of thousands
of malaysians protested against najib
and his governments but najib still had
faith he could stay in power and that
everything would be fine but as expected
he lost the next election and was
arrested for trying to flee the country
in 2018 and joe lowe he was long gone
almost a billion dollars of the money he
still haven't seized but joe himself has
disappeared into thin air all we know
for sure today is that he's somewhere in
china his love for luxury and fame
didn't die down though as he sometimes
spotted in clubs or private parties only
to disappear soon after the last widely
reported sighting of him in the news was
ironically in wuhan back in february
2020 when the world was getting really
riled up
the reason why joe lowe was able to pull
off one of the greatest hikes in history
is because government funds are not
transparent at all here is how it works
the government takes money from you at
the point of a gun in the form of taxes
and they'll say it's for important
infrastructure think airports hospitals
research facilities or california's
high-speed rail that burned through 100
billion dollars projects that provide
people with electricity housing water
healthcare internet transportation etc
and then they funnel your money into
private companies that build that
infrastructure the problem is in many
cases the only companies that get these
contracts are the friends and families
of the politician the public has no idea
how this money is being spent there is
no incentive to spend the money well
money just gets taken from your wallet
and is transferred to the pockets of
your politicians friends and family the
problem is these infrastructure projects
these we'll call them public private
partnerships or p3s for short are
actually really important not only
because they provide crucial
infrastructure for us but because they
can be an extremely profitable
investments
but as we mentioned public-private
partnerships have only ever been
available to the ultra wealthy and are
ripe with corruption thanks to how not
transparent they are that's where
something called delta p3 comes in much
like startups that have democratized
investing in things like fine arts delta
p3 democratizes investing into these
large-scale infrastructure projects that
move the world forward an asset class
has estimated to reach 3.8 trillion
dollars by 2040. that is more than the
entire crypto market combined that means
when they launch average everyday
investors like yourselves will finally
be able to get a piece of this pie and
it solves the problem of transparency in
p3s by putting this murky industry onto
a public unchangeable blockchain with
delta p3 being backed by avalanche if
this sounds even remotely compelling to
you go to jake.yt delta p3 to join their
discord server and you'll be first in
line to know when this revolution in
public private partnerships is launching
it's completely free you can leave the
discord server whenever you want so you
have nothing to lose go to jake.yt delta
p3 with the link below and join now
thanks to delta p3 for sponsoring this
video
[Music]
[Music]
you